hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar 3d organoid models for
wrenchy ation of PSC derive dopaminergic
neurons I'm Kristy Jewell of Labatt's
and I will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinth and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information on our sponsor
please visit the sponsor tab on the left
side of your screen now let's get
started I would like to remind everyone
that today's event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of your presentation window or use
that ask a question box to let us know
you're experiencing a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I would
now like to introduce to you today's
speaker dr. Richard Josephson senior
staff scientist cell biology 3d models
at Thermo Fisher Scientific for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
dr. Josephson welcome you may now begin
your presentation
Thank You Christy for that introduction
my name is Richard Jazmin I'm here to
talk to you about 3d organoid models for
differentiation of pluripotent stem cell
derived dopaminergic neurons
so as you're probably aware if you're
watching this seminar in the past few
years there's been a boom of
publications on organoids and other 3d
culture systems for studying the human
brain here at thermo Fisher some of our
customers are trying to catch up with
that boom and so they're asking us some
introductory questions such as how do I
get started
culturing organoids and our 3d models
really better than 2d and how do i model
my particular research area in organize
so the work I'm going to discuss today
was undertaken in response to those sort
of customer inquiries but it focuses on
a much narrower question namely can
thermo Fisher's existing 2d culture
systems be used to generate midbrain
organoids and to model Parkinson's
disease
as you're probably aware of Parkinson's
disease is a progressive
neurodegenerative disease in which a
specific type of neuron the a9
dopaminergic neuron of the substantial
[ __ ] is lost in large numbers while
other neurons are largely spared
ourselves a set of three media which
have been optimized to specify expand
and mature human dopaminergic neurons
from pluripotent stem cells in 2d
culture this is the PSC dopaminergic
neuron differentiation kit shown at the
top of the stick slide
the top of the chart is the workflow
that's been optimized for 2d
differentiation specification occurs in
attached culture and bicha nekton
followed by two passages on to laminate
at day 16 the dissociated cells can be
proud preserved if you wish after day 16
the floor plate cells are expanded in
suspension culture for five days and
then passage Don topology lexing laminin
for the final maturation at the bottom
of the figure is in alternative workflow
that my colleagues and I at thermo
Fisher who worked out to form midbrain
organoids in 3d I'm going to walk you
through this procedure in detail but for
now I just want to point out a few
highlights first we're beginning by
culturing the pluripotent stem cells
themselves in 3d in this new suspension
medium the cells are passaged
only once instead of several times
right at the beginning of
differentiation to reduce any
irregularity in the size of the spheroid
and of course the cells are kept in
rotation or in suspension and Static
culture for the duration of
differentiation as I'll show you we have
found that specification and expansion
of floorplate progenitors can be
completed in a much shorter time in 3d
eleven days and the bottom workflow
versus 21 days in the 2d workflow at top
both methods produce a similar purity of
floorplate progenitors
while also promoting the functional
state of the resulting dopaminergic
neurons
you
so here's the data on the floor plate
specification efficiency we are using
two markers antibiotics to the nuclear
factors Fox a2 and otx two to mark
progenitors that have a midbrain floor
plate identity
cells that you see here have been
passaged and replated as monolayers
either after 21 days of differentiation
in 2d and the left column or 11 days of
differentiation in 3d in the right
column antibiotic standing reveals that
in either case greater than 90 percent
of the cells co-expressed fox a2 and ot
x2
that's 3d specification reaches the same
efficiency as 2d specification but in
much less time
this next figure shows what happens if
you take those cultures that have been
specified and expanded in 3d and then
replated it in 2d out a little further
so with the standard 2d differentiation
protocol you go out to day 35 five weeks
of culture and then you can stain four
th+ neurons whereas with the 3d protocol
when you dissociate at day eleven and
plate them by day 25 you see abundant
th+ neurons and if i zoom in a little
bit
you can see that the th+ neurons in both
cases are positive for the midbrain
marker fox a2
so to go back to the workflow slide this
for a moment I want to zoom in bit on
the details of this and talk about a
number of variations that we've tried to
the protocol in order to optimize
differentiation of dopaminergic neurons
in 3d
so first zooming in the input as I
mentioned is spheroid
of IPSC cells round in rotating culture
these are generally passaged every four
days but we have found that the clumps
one day after passages are generally the
optimal size for switching to the floor
plate specification media so that is
what they look like on day zero when we
switch the specification
after two days specification you can see
that there are outgrowth of epithelial
thin epithelial sheets of cells on the
sides which by day six are beginning to
greatly thickened you switch these
cultures into expansion media at this
point and that allows the spirits to
grow up into these irregular shapes with
that translucent outer layer and I was
keep growing in size until week three or
four differentiation
if and
alternative to this
and some of the steroids in
extracellular matrix fairly in
differentiation this is a very commonly
used protocol for neural organ which we
embedded in cold gel tracks day 2 or day
7 and see an immediate response in the
formation of these little bubbles of
epithelium on all sides of the organized
two weeks of differentiation the
embedded organize seemed to consist of
convoluted sheets itself
for weeks the that complex structure
remain but cells and the rats can both
be seen growing out into the capsule of
extracellular matrix
you
we also explored another set of
alternative in hopes of producing more
uniform organized this time with passage
the IPSC sells into low attachment
round-bottom 96-well plates which are
called nun clone sphere plate we plate
selves evenly to all wells and one day
later we get a single small spheroid /
well a very consistent diameter across
the plate that's day zero for the floor
plate specification these small
spheroids respond to the addition of
specification media by growing out
bubbles of epithelium similarly to what
we saw with the ECM embedding
this time switching into expansion media
allows those epithelial bubbles to grow
outward without any constraint and by
three weeks this is thickened in to give
very irregular shapes but at least the
sizes of the organoids are somewhat more
uniform so we decided once again that we
should add extracellular matrix
during specification hour this time
instead of embedding the early spheroids
a day - which is very labor intensive
we simply added two percent gel tricks
to the medium and then kept it cold was
not to allow it to gel
at the end of the specification period
these organized don't look bubbly at all
but when you put them into expansion
media you can see that they do have many
thin translucent bumps of epithelial
cells I'll show you in a bit that the
convoluted outer structure is retained
through further differentiation
so it was a little hard for us to
believe that dilute extracellular matrix
could really change the epithelial
structure of these floor plate spirits
here we looked at spirits after one week
of differentiation in the U bottom wells
with or without the allude extracellular
matrix and looking just at the Dappy
stay in nuclei we see that 200
micrograms per mil of mouse laminate
induces a major outgrowth of these
hollow bubbles themselves while two
percent gel tricks does pretty much the
same thing for less money although it's
a little bit less striking
we look also looked at the structures by
staining for the epithelial polarity
marker and CAD here
and we saw that extra Soviet matrix
partly partially altered the
distribution of any CAD hiren into the
lumens of these little bubbles or
rosette like structures but it's not a
completely black and white change
next to see how these alternative
workflows affect neuronal
differentiation we compared the
organoids
at three weeks by hole mount
immunostaining the organoids were
stained with antibodies and cleared with
the site of this dairy agent and then
imaged on the cell inside cx-7 laser
high content analysis instrument
so the first example here is from
free-floating organoids specified in
rotating culture at three weeks these
have abundant map to positive neurons
around the outside in red while the
tyrosine hydroxylase positive
dopaminergic neurons marked in green are
subpopulation with relatively short
projection by comparison when you embed
these
same organoids in extracellular matrix
you get a larger organization three
weeks that has a large subset of th
positive dopaminergic neurons both da
neurons also have longer projections
than we saw in the free-floating
organoid and so could be more mature you
can also see that those convoluted cell
layers are maintained particularly when
you look at a single optical section
now the organoids that were specified in
static culture in a you bottom plate
look at three weeks
a bit like the embedded organized taffy
shows that the structure is less compact
than the free-floating organoids and
features a population of elongated th+
neuron like the embedded organoids
finally the addition of dilute gel treks
to the static organoids produces a more
regular shape that gives a convoluted
outer layer with abundant th+ neurons I
don't have map to staining available on
this yet but I will see when looking at
a single optical plane on this organ
right you can see how these the
dopaminergic neurons have cell bodies
that are distributed across that deeply
crevasse surface
this is also visible in the next slide
which is a three week old or going to
inform Denis you bottom well with gel
tricks and stained four th and the
midbrain progenitor marker box a - you
can see how the dopaminergic projections
cover the surface but th positive in
their cell bodies can also be seen at
the surface or deep below it this is a
bit more obvious when you look at the
single optical section on the right this
makes it difficult to see whether the
progenitors in the post mitotic neurons
occupy separate layers and is very
wrinkly epithelia covering the surface
so now I want to talk about maturation
of the dopaminergic neurons
dopaminergic neurons in the brain
produce a pigment called neuro melanin
it's a direct byproduct of dopamine
synthesis and neuro melanin is the
substance that makes the substantial
[ __ ] whack several recent publications
of midbrain organoids have noted that
neuro melanin appears in their organized
after a hundred or more days culture so
it's perhaps not surprising that our ECM
encapsulated organoids have dots of
pigmentation after nine or ten weeks of
differentiation
however the onion capsulated were free
floating organized
show very little pigment in the same
timeframe
you may also have noticed that the
encapsulator organoids by 10 weeks have
become much larger this appears to be
because that capsule of gel Trek is
completely filled up with cells and cell
projections
now dilute 2% gel tricks added to view
bottom plate
also promotes normal and progressive
production in the UN the organoid we can
see the pigment easily at nine weeks but
oddly enough we also can detect that
pigment in most of the organized by only
five weeks
far the dead week gel tracks in the you
bottom well is the only treatment that
produces Nura melanin as early as five
weeks
so we see additional evidence of early
maturation in these organized when we
take them to record electrical activity
so the
pictures of midbrain organoids that have
been plated on to multi electrode arrays
from accion bio system in the acción
plate each well contains 16 electrodes
for recording electrical activity
you can attach whole organoids to these
although as you can see in the pictures
it's difficult to exactly cover all 16
electrodes
these organized were plated at three
weeks before the neuro melanin was
apparent then took about two weeks
before we could record the first bursts
of spontaneous electrical activity the
bursts were sometimes recorded by only a
single electrode and sometimes
coordinated across four or five
electrodes and in these raster plots the
coordinated bursts are indicated by a
vertical pink line
because dopaminergic neurons can
reappear neurotransmitter via the
dopamine transporter adding excess
dopamine to medium temporarily silences
activity so here addition dopamine at
one hundred micro molar to the medium
reduced electrical activity and silenced
all of the coordinated bursts indicating
that dopaminergic neurons responsible
wash out the excess dopamine restored
the network activity what we saw at five
weeks was just the first glimmers of
spontaneous activity but by seven weeks
we could see increased bursting and
increased coordination
however this activity remains very slow
compared to what dopaminergic neurons
can do in a monolayer of culture as
you'll see in the next slide
so my colleague Michael Dirr took a
different approach to recording activity
of his IPSC derived dopaminergic neurons
as I told you about with the Fox 8200
txt scanning
Michael performed floorplate
specification and expansion in 3d for 11
days before dissociating the organoids
and replacing them onto the mah surface
so in that specification expansion are
performed in 2d the neurons produce
rhythmic coordinated bursts by six weeks
of differentiation which you can see in
the raster plot on the left
however specification and expansion of
floorplate in 3d produces stronger and
more frequent purses before five weeks
in differentiation as you see in the
raster plot on the right so we're
getting more activity in shorter amount
of time Michael also compared the mean
firing rate the synchrony and the
fraction of active electrodes for
neurons replated from 2d or 3d cultures
in each of two cell lines specification
of floorplate in 3d led to higher mean
firing rate greater synchrony across
electrodes and activity across a wider
area of the well also if you look
carefully at these graphs each of these
characteristics reached its maximum
earlier in 3d specified dopaminergic
nerve
so as you've seen we have not yet
recorded comparable activity within
intact organize this may just be reality
or it may reflect poor contact between
the organoids and the surface electorate
nevertheless we have evidence that
organoid culture promotes dopaminergic
maturation I want to briefly discuss the
possibilities of using midbrain
organoids to model Parkinson's disease
so even among the most elderly adults
the rate of Parkinson's is just under 2%
so we cannot model the disease with just
any pluripotent stem cell line but
numerous mutations have been identified
in the genome which greatly increase the
risk of the disease by incorporating
these mutations into our model we have a
better chance of observing disease like
phenotypes in vitro
many mutations that are common among
Parkinson's patients occur in the genes
for alpha-synuclein and LR RK 2
B alanine 32 prolene mutation in alpha
synuclein leads to protein misfolding
and this folded alpha synuclein is a
major component of the levy bodies found
in degenerating dopaminergic neurons
upon autopsy
lr rk2 mutations are the most common
genetic cause of Parkinson's disease and
the glycine 2019 to Syrian mutation is
found in many familial Parkinson's cases
and also about 1% of sporadic cases so
both of these mutations were engineered
sorry each of these mutations were
engineered into the same IPSC line using
CRISPR calf 9 technology by thermo
Fisher's custom services team
after introducing the single base pair
changes the cells were sorted to obtain
clonal line
sequencing demonstrated that the desired
single nucleotide polymorphisms were
homozygous in anywhere from 4% to 48% of
the clones
so our next step is to test whether
these disease related mutations make the
cell line more susceptible to stress
first we can test for a phenotype of
these mutations in the IPS see lines
themselves numerous compounds will
increase stress and trigger apoptosis in
IPS C or presented itself to that are
very commonly used are store sportin a
broad range protein kinase inhibitor and
hydrogen peroxide which induces
oxidative stress we use store sporran to
test for the phenotype of the alpha
synuclein mutation in the IPS sea lion
as i'll show you in a moment
second we can look for disease like
phenotypes immature midbrain organized
here are the phenotype that we want to
see is selective apoptosis in
dopaminergic neurons while other neurons
and non-neuronal cells are spared
a number of compounds are frequently is
for inducing this phenotype in animals
or in culture including six hydroxy
dopamine which is specifically taken up
by DA neurons
wrote known which inhibits mitochondrial
complex one MPP Plus which is a toxic
metabolite of mptp and induces reactive
oxygen species or mg 132 which inhibits
the proteasome that's just a few many
compounds that are frequently is I'm
going to show you a bit of data using
rotenone as their stress
but first we're going to test for an
effect of the a 30 P mutation in the
IPSC themselves
and how we expand PSC and suspension
culture here's a picture of the
spheroids of undifferentiated IPSC we
can induce apoptosis in these by adding
stores foreign and detect its effect
with a green dye called sullivan
caspase-3 7 that flores's after
activation by caspase-3 or 7 that our
regulators of the caspase activation
apoptosis pathway
exposure to a range of concentrations in
store sporran looks like this this is
the responsive so event die
and when we quantitate that fluorescence
in live spheroids we get curves like
this so here we can see that the a 30 P
mutation is shifting the IDI 54 store is
foreign
next we're going to try to perform a
similar assay in more mature midbrain
organized
so
these are midbrain organized generated
from alpha-synuclein 8:30 p.m. uten and
wild-type lines after three weeks of
differentiation these were exposed to
rotenone for 24 hours followed by the
cell event castes die then the organoids
were stained with th antibody and imaged
his whole mounts on the cx-7
high-content system
the magenta color is the th staining in
dopaminergic neurons while the green is
castes death
you may notice that the extent of the th
staining is progressively reduced with
the increasing drug concentration while
the caspase dye increases but neither of
these measures declines to zero on
either end of the scale which effects
our quantitation
when we measure either caspase
activation on the left or th positive
neuron degradation on the right singly
in whole organoids
we can see that it's difficult to fit
the typical sigmoid of those response
carriers in this case the wild-type cell
line represented by the blue is a little
better behaved and fitting that
sigmoidal model than the mutant this
tells us more experiments are necessary
alternatively
attempt to measure the activation of
caspase specifically in the dopaminergic
neurons
coulomb to do so we've used an antibody
specific for activated gas stage 3
these are hole mounts of three-week-old
organized stained for tyrosine
hydroxylase and active caspase-3 and
cleared with sight of these two reagent
and again imaged on b c x7 it's not
it's not particularly easy to
co-localize the two antibodies the
strategy that we've used is on the next
slide
so we try to focus on single cells
within these densely packed we're going
to leads by segmenting the images on
daffy as you see in the image in the
center of the row and exclude larger
areas where staffy positive nuclei
overlap then we score each of those
segmented particles for the intensity of
caspase-3 and intensity of th
this is how it looks if you are doing
this on a z stack projection but what
we're actually doing is the same process
on every optical section
allows you to more narrowly focus on the
cells that are in focus in each section
it's very data and labor-intensive so
given the slow progress on this we're
starting to focus on work in
cross-section torque in the heads
instead
so here we are looking at five week old
organoids the same age at which we can
see the first glimmers of electrical
activity
and the staining here is th in green for
the dopaminergic neurons in red is the
active caspase-3
that there are th+ there on below the
surface of the spheres as I described
before we're in the presence of high
concentrations of the rotenone on the
right we can see that you can see that
there's nuclear fragmentation and a
great deal of caspase activation close
to the surface
but in the untreated spheroid on the
Left we still get a fairly high
background of active caspase-3 as you
have probably read recently most
organoid cultures are under a lot of
stress due to lack of oxygen and
mechanical stress from being stirred so
that is probably contributing to our
high background here and one of the
projects what we're working on is
maintenance media for organoids that
will help to reduce that stress
if we look at the numbers of co-localize
th neurons with active gas phase three
out of cryo section you can start to get
decent numbers but the high background
again is making curve fitting difficult
that's where we are to date I just want
to run through
few conclusions from this work first is
that the thermo Fisher kit for 2d
directed differentiation can be used to
generate midbrain organoids
and we found that suspension culture of
pluripotent stem cells is an excellent
starting point for 3d cultures partly
because there's no adaptation required
to get into 3d when you're already in 3d
and partly because the suspension
culture allows you to scale up quite a
bit
also we find that the floorplate
specification and expansion is quite
accelerated in 3d compared to 2d
furthermore the maturation of
dopaminergic neurons themselves is
faster in 3d doing the floorplate
specification in 3d gives you earlier
and stronger neuronal activity than 2d
specification and we found that seeding
of the organ woods in the nun clones
Fira new bottom plates with 2% gel
tricks accelerates the th neuron
maturation as indicated by neuro melanin
and electrical activity and finally
Parkinson's disease modeling in 3d
organoids is possible with the the IPSC
spheroid incorporating mutations made by
CRISPR cast 9 we can show effect of
mutations
in IPSC the more mature organoids are
good for demonstrating functionality of
th positive neurons but the assays are
much more difficult to do and are very
little throughput so that is all I have
to say except for thank you very much
for listening to this seminar I hope
you're all you all stay well and I'd
like to open it up to any questions
thank you dr. Josephson for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of our
webinar now to our audience if you have
a question you would like to ask please
do so now just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we will answer as many
of your questions as we have time for
okay let's get started with some great
questions coming in dr. Joseph Dunn our
first question canvas system produce
organoids at a large scale
so the system is we have it produces
organized that what I'm going to call
medium throughput the throughput is
certainly higher than if you are
encapsulating organoids which is very
labor-intensive but it's not as high
throughput as if you are going directly
from the PSC suspension culture through
bulk specification of spheroids into
organoids
so we would like it to get to the high
throughput but we're working on that
very good now next question do you have
any products for organized of other cell
types or tissues
so there is a large effort within thermo
Fisher to produce products for a variety
of organized from different types of
brain cells liver cells cancer organoids
cardiac organoids and for the most part
those projects are all in process
okay dr. Jessup's and can thermo make
organoids for me so I mentioned that we
have a custom services team in Carlsbad
California and they have collected all
of the protocols from various people
working on organize within the company
and are ramping up to make organized as
a custom product so yes I would take
contact to sales rep asking about custom
services
very good and we have timbre one more
question how big do your organoids get
well my organoids start out at about 200
250 microns want to begin the
specification they grow to approximately
a millimeter in diameter by the time I
am doing my assays so as you saw in the
MEA pictures they're just about cover
all of the electrodes and a48 well MEA
thank you dr. Josephson now before we go
I'd like to thank our audience for
joining us and for their interesting
questions questions we were unable to
answer live today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by dr. Josephson the other
email address you provided at the time
of registration I would like to once
again thank dr. Richard Josephson for
his time today we'd also like to thank
laberd's and our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
Mavericks will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share by email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and we
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon